traditionally the Enlightenment came
first then came the revolutions but in
today's Beijing it's the other way
around the former revolutionary History
Museum on Tiananmen Square has been
renamed the National Museum of China its
courtyard has been enclosed giving the
building with its military contours and
square colonnades a total of about two
hundred thousand square meters floor
space now it's said to be the biggest
Museum on earth it's set to open on
April first with a special exhibition
not a Chinese but an international one
it's themed the art of the Enlightenment
the architects for the renovation were
the hamburg-based firm gear con mark and
partners the exhibition is to run for
one year it's 600 works spanning the
18th century when Europe throw off the
yoke of political and religious
absolutism to bring the Enlightenment to
Tiananmen Square scene of the 1989
student protests that were crushed by
the military with much bloodshed it's a
feat of logistics and at the same time a
masterpiece of diplomacy it's a cultural
mission with a political edge
the director general of the dresden
state art collections and a pioneer of
cultural exchange with china talks about
how to make foreign policy with art it's
almost routine for many other European
countries but for Germany this is a
first he speaks for everyone involved
the scheme it's important to emphasize
that the initiative came from our
Chinese partners during a state visit by
the German president at the time Horst
kurla they proposed that we sign a joint
agreement on it in the presence of Horst
cooler and who Jintao sank in what phone
hung column which Intel this highest
hisses política flunky so all the
political maneuvering and the really
intense effort that the former foreign
minister frank-walter Steinmeier put
into it paid off he even got involved in
the content aspect doesn't rely begin
dessert these are very clear signals
that politics and culture interact and
the support from the private sector was
fabulous as in limos here we finally
managed to get all the partners together
on one side for a public exhibition in
sort of it from leaking bastidores
olympic in this time too it's also a
signal of interest in this topic and
it's a result of China's resonance with
Germany which I'm every bit as proud of
as I am of the exhibition as well analia
and the importance is reflected in the
funding structure eighty percent of the
financial support came from the German
Foreign Ministry
the exhibition the art of the
Enlightenment is a 10 million euro gift
from the German taxpayer augmented by
funding from sponsors
the National Museum of China is paying
the insurance but no loan fees a radical
departure from the usual practice for
international exhibitions but even the
best-laid plans often go awry the
opening of both museum and exhibition
was postponed several times which is
only to be expected when dealing with
such a large building and up to 30,000
visitors a day it's a massive challenge
even by Chinese standards it may seem
paradoxical that Europe's intellectual
Awakening and striving for freedom would
interest an authoritarian single-party
system on the one hand it welcomes the
Enlightenment and on the other it still
shuns terms like civil society in the
year 2011 in fact there never was any
such thing as an art of the
Enlightenment 18th century art maybe
rokoko or neo classicist prints or
politics adil or inferno the 600 works
on display in beijing represent the art
of an epic not an epic an art
the op's of you is to just be stunned
the European enlightenment is in fact
part of both the school and university
curriculum in China so the European
enlightenment is a concept here
especially as manifested in literature
and philosophy by Lessing and can't
among the Germans and of course by
Rousseau among the French that's unless
the occasion of glorious I just keep
ungrateful spoon so they have these
points of reference but for this
exhibition we set ourselves the task of
investigating and pursuing the
interpretation and visualization of the
Enlightenment in images its effects on
art and European culture and
contemporary thought no patient worked
on that with our Chinese counterparts
and I think we came up with a good
concept doesn't him knots again this is
akeem isn't a hospital since the Chinese
are well aware and openly acknowledge
that the European enlightenment had a
global significance for the cultural
systems of the world of the court was a
statement of it humans and their
self-determination in society and the
universe are very closely connected to
thinking of the Enlightenment which owes
the freedom and self-determination of
people as individuals are inconceivable
without the French Revolution and the
European enlightenment when this
epidemic is mentioned as individual is
owner fancy revolucion once the oil page
of Cleo miss tanga
but individual liberty and
self-determination in China is still a
long way off in Beijing enlightenment is
still just about art not reality
unpacking and examining the German
museum's treasures is down to the
Germans themselves any enthusiasm on the
Chinese side is still purely academic
no difficult
here's my premium then
we're between here we look after the
exhibits until they're in the display
case or on the wall after that it's the
National Museums responsibility we found
total was not in a museum on to our
Chinese counterparts and the Chinese
restorers are on hand to examine the
pc's condition and sign for them or they
notice things that they want written
down confess twizzy Zagros measurement
off fiska hug and when we take down the
exhibition in the years time we'll be
doing the return handover and our
Chinese counterparts have to be able to
show that everything has remained
unchanged in demonic mahina the moment
china rose to become a world power it
was advisable for it to get acquainted
with the conceptual foundations of its
partners in the global arena wien tiem
you keep designing this has a long
tradition during the Enlightenment in
the 18th century Jesuits traveled to
China to establish contact nike mag
revive and the chinois silly that
appeared in the art of the European
courts became world famous in the 18th
century those are some of the most
precious objects do you first movement
as cost passing of reasons and the
Exodia should be Griff the concept of
the exotic contains the idea of the
faraway disorder my novel english hbu
abba not do the 18th century China
played the part of the exotic land for
some kind it still does today no go
under but of course the philosophical
development of society is different in
Europe from what it was in China Oh
spiritum vaguely individual
eigenschaften
as in peeking gettest smile on the one
hand the Beijing exhibition is about the
significance of art in the Enlightenment
and on the other it's about the
significance of the Enlightenment for
art after the Enlightenment both are
fascinating themes for European cultural
and intellectual history densa mine is
the sock the 18th century was a time of
unparalleled revolution in art and media
new media were invented steel and wood
engraving and lithography for example
that allowed images to be reproduced in
numbers inconceivable in the previous
centuries Florida theatre in India all
at once art became a mass medium and
started exerting a powerful influence on
public thought in the mentality terrific
I'd guns and shiet so behind frozen even
so fast just as fascinating is the
thesis that the mindscape of the 18th
century the ideas of the Enlightenment
decisively influenced our idea of art
down to the present day in fact the
mindscape of the 20th century and early
21st century is still made by
enlightenment silence Francis yeah well
nuts no made by enlightenment
the history of art is the history of
ideas as well but only gradually did the
ideas of the Enlightenment begin
appearing in the imagery of the 18th
century long bound to the courts of the
nobility art tended to be conservative
the Beijing exhibition reflects this it
illustrates an epic that proved a
turning point for Europe but does not
analyze it it cautiously introduces the
Chinese viewer to a delicate subject
matter done some unfunded invictus Guyot
when we started we had to decide between
two very different exhibition concepts
we could have done the whole thing
chronologically and told the story of
the 18th century from 1702 1800 but we
could never figure out when exactly the
Enlightenment began and when it ended it
seemed much more fruitful for us to
divide the exhibition into theme attic
sections 120 stay long enough to
matteson six children you have my eye on
capital since we have a chapter called
near and far it's about European arts
first encounter with art from beyond
Europe just imagine in the 18th century
Chinese art suddenly began rippling into
the European art world the China trend
became one of the main trends of the
18th century liveness even idealized
China as the Europe of the east yeah
tokina fuga some oil hope our this
Austin's own for bikinis is it was no
different for the Chinese side China was
a highly advanced civilization and it to
realized for the first time in the 18th
century that there was a parallel
civilization over in Europe so China
also became aware of the world's
diversity in the 18th century and of the
necessity for the tolerance it needed to
exist with that diversity that we love
honesty respect alpha minus 40 feet high
right now so hot
the ausstellung gift of the nearly 2,500
square meters of exhibition space gives
all the pieces adequate room and the
generous layout allows us to put
together a synopsis of the widely
differing types of objects window seat
is your objective air intake on video we
shouldn't regardless exhibition in
Beijing as a conventional exhibition of
paintings or prints these conventional
forms serve to separate the media from
one another instead of bringing them
together so for us to this exhibition is
a kind of strategic experimental lab
we're developing an exhibition format
that doesn't exist yet in Germany in
this forum hosted on static is just
experiment you fed yeah in wauconda I
know stealing's format that is so in
deutschland more carnage hips
Terry Tatum war tomoko double wedding
done in our national museum here in
China the emphasis is on history as well
as art Jonna literally we've mixed
genres here in the past you could put
hundred either but offering single
genres such as painting alone or
sculpture alone makes it hard to put
across an overall impression of an epic
and Chinese history dahan io non cuando
yo you go v12 evo so after some
consultation our German counterparts
also chose this kind of exhibition
format for the 18th century you're
telling Colton humming it to the church
you got a few know how to channel shirt
shinhwa's re and puppet theaters from
Dresden stand next to paintings from
eunuch or marbles and costumes from
Berlin commemorative coins porcelain
tableware early scientific instruments
like a camera obscura a vacuum pump or
an electrostatic generator or an early
globe where the name of china isn't even
mentioned the art of the Enlightenment
is conceived as a light-hearted stroll
through a century that few Chinese are
familiar with whenever possible replicas
offer the opportunity to touch and
explore the objects represent high art
and everyday life they can be
sentimental bric-a-brac or precious
items from life at court
in European museums art objects are
normally grouped by type and form and
the institution's work independently
what's different about this exhibition
is its public funding and diplomatic aim
of deepening the dialogue with China the
world power and China the marketplace
the cooperation between three of
Germany's largest museum networks is
also a departure from business as usual
it proved every bit as complicated to
work out as the cooperation with China
starting with the selection of pieces to
loan and on through the transport
logistics and compiling the catalogue
on the outside it may have looked like
peace and harmony but on the inside it
took a strict but delicate touch to
avoid stepping on anyone's toes as iska
at least assured desala show is what's
extraordinary about this exhibition is
the fact that the big three german
museum networks got together on a joint
effort which right from the start and
through the entire process was not only
the goal but their entire approach the
soul as uh Kaleta Zoe foodist assurance
loop dollars I'd see it as the highest
compliment if the specific contributions
that berlin dresden or munich have made
to the exhibition could no longer be
recognized except maybe by the objects
the various collections of land since
I'm not biased but here I'm standing in
front of one of the prime objects in the
exhibition it came from the Berlin
collection I naked danica by Christian
Gottlieb chick it played a key role in
the imagery of the 19th century almost
right up to the reception of the French
Revolutions ideals as noise at your
notes that is the accordionist you could
say it's the icon of the exhibition
shakes hind leg and an anchor it's the
icon of the exhibition in the sense that
it so convincingly expresses the
Enlightenment image of mankind through
art in fact like no other work in the
exhibition defiance be if how it's a
sculptors wife portrayed by a painter in
the colors of the French Revolution free
on a hilltop free of all societies
constraints entirely preoccupied with
herself that's the new human being of
the Enlightenment as is the nya men
stealth kill
the Mashona you two more that we don't
find her daughter with China's pictorial
tradition is different from Europe's do
we try to select the work so they
provide the Chinese viewers with a red
thread through the historical epic and
social origins of the enlightenment
shall we begin siento party easily in
karate life the whole family waiting
room with this help the viewers see how
the works relate to one another
université de and they can gain a deeper
understanding of history they deceive of
you she don't get heated what I 20
hammer in the run-up to the opening the
Chinese media have been reporting
extensively on the exhibition official
circles less so fishbones des shine else
become does it was important for us to
include the perspective that the
Enlightenment was not completed with the
end of the 18th century maybe also its
impact reaches into the 20th century
your boredom at Salon des sciences that
saw their birth in 18th century have
developed further of course the same
applies to the arts dance once it's
leandra in the 20th century art is no
longer about the representational
quality but about meditations that focus
in the art medium itself by McMurtry
another bullet through and of course
that started a revolution that only
serves to reveal how virulent all these
questions remain today cortical bleeders
and escape it's still all about the
freedom of art the freedom of thought
about creating opportunities for a
society to develop democratically and
about allowing the individual to find
his or her place in society on the one
hand and on the other hand about how
societies have to work in relation to
one another Tony Anderson imbecile swine
Honda
man who design are still on secuencia
off care when people hear that an
exhibition on the art of the
Enlightenment is in preparation for
Beijing everyone's first thought is
provocation but this exhibition was
never seen as a provocation by our
Chinese counterparts at the national
museum or as an ideological interloper
if your locus of frames kappa so i'm on
the contrary our Chinese counterparts
have given us the feeling again and
again that the Enlightenment is an
indispensable part of their own national
awareness the steadiness assist the
Marxist thought from which 20th century
Chinese history drew its dynamism is
viewed by our Chinese colleagues as a
legacy of the Enlightenment in autonomic
and fight at HUD good so to Chinese
viewers the topic of the Enlightenment
most likely does not represent a break
but illustrates an experience of
continuity that they share in East Asia
public conversations gakkai box and an
illustrator and continuity it's a
lateness dustman hut for the
exhibition's opening the National Museum
had a surprise in store a 10 metre tall
statue of the long suppressed
philosopher Confucius
he discoursed upon the importance of
knowledge and learning two and a half
thousand years ago an early signal of
China's own enlightenment
or it may simply be a reminder that
progress is only possible through
curiosity prosperity through individual
initiative and success through ingenuity
the European enlightenment made history
as an epoch of emancipation emancipation
of the individual of science and the
arts Denis Diderot published his
encyclopedia a first data bank of
general knowledge museums were created
that were open to the public there were
visions of an education through the Arts
the exhibition China and the art of the
Enlightenment will be accompanied by a
flurry of lectures and discussion forums
it could hardly be expected not to put
ideas about education freedom and
individualism squarely into the
spotlight in Beijing but doesn't have a
real chance at reaching its target
audience the blood system vision field
I'm sure gentleman square is one of the
world's best-known squares these and
this exhibition is being held in this
profoundly political spot with a
profoundly political theme of the
Enlightenment of clear Nizam deserts no
knowledge this is an exhibition that's
very conspicuously taking place at the
same time as the opening of the
renovated museum their social era and it
must be quite a heavy burden to be
carrying around you'd have to strike
just exactly the right note to put
across the right message so I until it
you pour chapter four little mountain
the art of the Enlightenment before the
eyes of the great Chairman Mao Zedong on
the very same square where the
demonstrations for democracy and
transparency came to a blood-soaked end
culture is always political and the
political is always a matter of culture